[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
calm presents the second annual fall
chess classic
[Music]
[Music]
happy weekend everybody welcome to the
st. Louis chess club where for most it's
their day off but not for these players
we're going straight through to the
finish line and we're only at the midway
point so come on into the studio
grab your pumpkin tis the season and
join us for round number four of the
fall chess classic my name is Ben Simon
and I'm joined as always by
international master Eric Rosen Eric
it's gonna be a fun day I'm so pumped
for today and seeing who's gonna emerge
in these fields I'm looking forward to a
- we had a peaceful day yesterday a lot
of draws but hopefully today will be a
bit more bloody oh my well let's see how
bloody it is so far first in Group A
these are the standings after three
rounds have been completed now yesterday
Alexey Draya dispatched of the chest
broth sorry for all of you youtubers out
there and he is now in clear lead with
two and a half points and then after
that man it's anybody's chess tournament
here what do you make of this so far
Eric yeah I'm impressed with Draya I
feel like he's the most solid player
based on the result and based on his
play he really just took the grind down
into Hansen yesterday one upon out of
the opening and converted it very clean
fashion so there's still many games to
go so we'll see if he can hold on to his
lead or if players just behind can catch
up also notable in this field hammer
actually he says I feel like I'm back in
this tournament after yesterday with a
big win as black against Dario spirits
so good job hammer and now that he's
rejuvenated let's see what kind of
campaign he can wage okay let's take a
look at the B group this is still really
strong event 24 2500 level players here
in this one and we see got boos Ian's
still at the top two and a half points
so what do you make of this here Eric I
mean it's nice to see clear leaders in
both sections we have at least two
players to keep our eyes on go boos ian
has been playing some some pretty fiery
chess though he had a quick draw
yesterday but
it seems like he's in the driver's seat
driver seat today and I mean we might
have him in the studio again he's
already been the studio twice after both
wins so he's always a pleasure to
interview so see what happens very
well-spoken yeah I mean he had a draw
everybody had a draw yesterday in Group
E which is unusual in this event we've
seen so many decisive games stuff that
you don't really see in events like the
Sinquefield Cup or London or anything
like that so there's a very exciting
tournament we have here and let's take a
look at the format of this event we know
a lot of you are joining us for the
first time since it is the weekend so
welcome it this is a 210 player
round-robin event we have an 8 group we
have a B group the time control for both
is 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
plus 30 minutes added on for the
remainder of the game after the player
hits their 40th move there is a 30
second increment from move number one so
that means all the players have to take
notation from beginning to end and very
important there is a 30 move no draw
rule in play which means that the
players cannot agree to a draw before
blacks thirtieth move and this is so we
get some fighting chess on the board we
don't want any of those seven move
grandmaster draws you know they call
them it sounds exciting you don't want a
grandmaster draw them that's not what
the spectators come for and now the
schedule we are in round number four of
nine there are no rest days and this is
an abbreviated commentary schedule
you'll notice that each rounds each day
the round begins at 1:00 p.m. and we are
on the air two and a half hours after
that at 3:30 p.m. Central Time
the last day we're starting earlier to
make room for playoffs if necessary
because there can only be one winner in
each field I do have a question will
there be an Armageddon playoff if there
are players tied in either group there
could be so I believe the the protocol
here is too rapid games best of two and
then after that if it's still tied
between the players then they'll go to
an army game and yes we will still have
playoffs even if there are three or four
people tied for first it's very unlikely
but it could happen
and in those instances I don't even know
of all the specifics are posted on u.s.
chess champs interesting so I assume
that the protocols are there but this
will not be like the grand chest or
where you know we have to get it down to
two for a playoff if there's a bunch of
people that need a playoff we're gonna
have a playoff between those people and
you can join us all along the way of
course you may be watching on YouTube
you could be watching us on Twitch be
sure to check out the live module at
u.s. chess champs com where we have
chess 24 embedded there oh so nice with
the video up in the corner analysis you
can turn the engine on or off it's
really up to you and follow us join the
conversation all on the way on all
platforms with hashtag fall chess
classic we want to hear from you and yes
we will be monitoring the chats today so
ask your questions be civil be
thoughtful we want to hear from you this
is gonna be a lot of fun we are already
underway though in round number four so
we're not going to waste too much more
time let's see what games we have in
store for you in group a these are the
pairings and we have a couple of games
already completed as you see there Eric
Hanson and Ray Robson have drawn alexei
gribov and Daario spirits have drawn and
then the games in progress was our over
zone versus URI clues above hammer
versus Akopian and then our key matchup
of the day that's right grandmaster
Sethuraman against grandmaster Lenderman
two heavy dogs playing in round four
they both have two points out of three
going into this round and if either
player wins they can catch up to the
leader Alexei dry of so we'll see we'll
see how the play is developing so far
let's take a look at how the game is
going I do want to take a look at the
opening because so thurman played one of
my favorite openings English opening
which I've played in in many tournament
games over the recent years and he
played what's called the four of nights
variation of the English and has a more
slow reputation especially after this
move pond III and what ended up
happening were was that both sides just
developed within their own territory and
neither player really
put a media pressure on their opponent
from early on we can see both sides kind
of minding their own business here
completing developments after e3 the
first somewhat strange move that we see
in this game is Knight to g4 allowing
the night to get kicked after pawn h3
and the knight repositions itself on
very seemingly bad square on h6 but if
we notice the point of this move is that
rather than being on f6 the knight is
now no longer in the way of a VAT pawn
and that can very soon gain space with
this move pawn f5 and that's exactly
what happened after Knight d2 pawn f5
it's very common in these sort of closed
English positions that Bach wants to
expand on the Kings side and maybe later
on get some King side attack very
possible ideas of perhaps pawns e5 pawn
f4 I played this myself is black in many
many games over the years now one
benefit for white in this position is
very nice control over the d5 square and
this is one of the kind of key elements
of playing the English opening is that
the bishop the knight and the pond
control D 5 and so thurman takes full
advantage of this by clapping the
Knights in to d5 and after Knight f7
play continues and it still took a while
for fireworks to happen but after the
move pawn to f4 we should admire White's
just very aesthetic set up with these
pawns quite symmetrical
controlling the center from all
directions
combined with the double fiend cadeau I
do like the way so Thurman is playing
here it just seems like a really nice
harmonious setup and it's kind of the
the type of position you want your
pieces to be on the good squares so that
if the position opens up further you'll
be prepared for the tactical
possibilities let's zoom forward here
many more moves have been played black
was fighting for d5 provoking light to
move back to c3 and it took a while
before anything got traded you can see
all the pieces still on the board and
then finally so Thurman decides to take
on e5 and then
go for afor transforming the structure
and perhaps trying to fix this pawn now
on e5 and it's very possible that this
pawn on e5 will be a long-term weakness
as White has ideas of rook to e1 perhaps
someday unleashing the bishop and mike
could potentially have multiple
attackers against the e5 pawn few more
moves have been played actually let me
update the board to the current position
after pony for Queen a5 and this is
where we see or we start seeing the
fireworks the Queen on a5 perhaps
applying a bit of pressure in White's
position white takes on f5 after Knight
take f5 94 putting the focus in the
center and then Lenderman played a
seemingly very risky move here Queen
take a to just going paw and grabbing
not sure if if I would approve of this
I'm sure yasser sarah one would approve
of this being the ultimate pollen
grabber but this seems very risky the
queen is now out of play should note
that black is threatening to take on e3
so after all I mean I'm not seeing how
how how can you make black pay here I
mean it looks like you can get in and
get out with that pawn I mean that's
very good question that I mean black
1upon is threatening to win another pawn
white would really like to play two
moves in a row here
- maybe cheats sneak the Queen on c2 and
then play rook a1 to trap the black
Queen so maybe actually now I'm
realizing if Queen c2 right away there
is a very deadly fork with 93 it's
working everything in White's territory
and I doubt that white would be happy
here not to mention the time situation
so it seems like Lenderman is really
putting the question to how his opponent
is going to find compensation here
having lost upon and being down on time
is that the current position right one
more move we see stuff going on just
played this move pawn g4 so rather than
focusing on targeting the black Queen
the focus is now on the Kings side I do
like this move
trying to click away the Knights maybe
remove it from accessing this III square
and if it retreats and maybe there's
this idea of Queen c2 or perhaps white
will continue with some attacking ideas
on the Kings side perhaps someday go for
a night f g5 and unleash the battery on
that file so seems like a very complex
battle so far if one of these players it
merges with a victory today I mean we
could be looking at a nuclear leader in
this field it's very true okay so in the
meantime since we've taken a look at our
key matchup in a let's look at our
lineup for Group B and all of the games
in Group B right now are still in
progress
Sergey Azeroth vs. Conrad old Chris you
versus Stevens earth
Brandon Jacobsen vs. L Shawn more via
body and akshat Chandra versus Ashwin
Jha ROM our last game is the key matchup
that's right good booze Ian's in clear
first in Group B playing Denis bar oh Sh
as we've seen who's playing some nice
chest so far not an easy player to
defeat let's take a look at the current
position lots of pieces have been trade
traded if we count the pawns it looks
like Denis is down the pawn if I'm
counting correctly five pawns versus
four points I direct yeah I I've I've
studied math in the past I guess I can
count I want to go back to a moment
several moves ago where it seems like
Denis just just made a very foolish
blunder if we take a look at this
position it seems roughly equal I mean
both sides having five pawns and very
symmetrical structure so you may wonder
how how black ended up losing a pawn
here if we go forward a few moves I
think it just came down to simple
tactics in this position it seems like
Denis just just got careless by playing
this move Bishop to c5 seems like an
innocent improving move optimizing the
bishop trying to make it more effective
perhaps glaring down at the f2 pawn
however whenever you move a piece in the
chess game
you gained control over some squares and
lose control over other squares in this
case because of bishop is no longer on
u7 there's less defense of the knight on
f6 and because of this there is a piece
that is overworked in blacks position
for viewers who are watching and may not
see the next move for light I would
highly encourage you to search for the
the tactical opportunity that white can
play in this position then do you have
any ideas what we can do well I think I
do that Bishop on taking h6 how about
that Bishop take a six this is g7 pawn
doing too many jobs at once if if it
were to take the bishop then the knight
is left completely undefended and that's
probably why black is regretting not
having the bishop still on e7 and what
happened from here after Bishop take h6
very sad move was played Bishop to f8
and white just went up a clear pawn
going forward here now it's a question
it can white actually convert the the
pawn advantage I think this is going to
take a lot more work to to go from being
up upon to winning it because there's no
clear weaknesses in Black's territory
it's not easy for white to create a
passed pawn and if white wants to
advance the pawns to gain space then
always have to be careful about
weakening the white king so I'm still
expecting a very long fight we see
Brooks do got traded here after Queen c5
Bishop g5
let's get forward to the current
position Queen d7 played a few more
moves have been played actually Bishop
to b4 f6 and now f4 and perhaps this is
a start of whites whites expansion on
the Kings side white has to be a bit
careful this movement f4 seems a little
bit weakening but it's also very
restrictive it's preventing this knight
from from moving to the only legal
Square on d5 and locks pieces now look
incredibly passive given that this
bishop is also stuck the bishop is
pinned to the king and attacked twice by
White's Queen and White's bishop so I
can't be too happy here
if I was Denish and should mention
they're on move 41 so both players
having a lot of time gooo Busey and has
over an hour on the clock which we don't
see too often we don't see the players
reaching move 40 with so much time to
spare so I'm liking White's chances in
this game you know there's a lot on the
line in this event and I'd like to take
a look at the prize funds for both
fields here first in Group A $22,000
total on the line the first-place winner
will be walking out with six grand
as far as Group B goes $14,000 total
prize fund and the champion goes home
with four thousand dollars okay so let's
look at the rest of our games here we
have in Group B one of the ones that
sticks out to me two players who are
really trying to get back into
contention the two players are in 9th
and 10th place respectively I'm talking
about Chris you and Stephen Zurich and
it looks well the board is very crowded
right now actually this position just
makes my head hurt it's hard to stare at
this and that just not get like a
terrible migraine just pieces just
scattered all over the place
black skiing on d7 Bishop on a four this
nine and a seven
seems like black is really lacking
coordination now this did come from a
French defense perhaps we can go back
and just take a look at the opening I
was taking a look at this game briefly
earlier and we see the classic winner or
variation of the French after a Bishop
to b4 + e5 and in this position that
Stephen Zerg played a very kind of
strange-looking move Queen d7 this is
now the move that you see every day at
least so early in the opening seems like
this is just blocking in blacks minor
pieces on the Queen side now I do want
to mention I'd believe desert played
this game earlier in the tournament I'm
not sure who it was against but I do
remember him playing this exact move and
it's very possible that Christopher was
preparing in this variation seemed like
he he played
quite quickly in the opening playing
queens of g4 and after after this attack
against the pawn on g7 now we see the
purpose of Queen d7 Black is able to
play f5 simultaneously defending the
pawn discovered defense and also
attacking the Queen on g4 and after
Queen to g3 then both sides began doing
their own thing getting their pieces
into play Bishop backed f8 seems
somewhat unusual and very sad move if I
were back here I would perhaps be a bit
more inclined to take on c3 but I guess
black did not want to concede the bishop
pair especially with white having
perhaps good potential with the dark
spirit bishop so bishop f8 keeps things
solid but black is is quite low on space
and going forward we do see black Castle
queenside going forward even more
Christopher you gaining space on the
Queen side and because White has not
committed the king yet it seems like
light will Castle very shortly on the
Kings side
White's main plan here is to attack on
the Queen side whenever there is
possibility for opposite side casting
you want to play more aggressively than
usual and that's what we see with this
Queen side pawn advance Steven played
Knight a5 here and after B take a 6
seems like white 1 upon but then the a
pawn has left a bit stranded on a 6
after Bishop to c6 very strange to have
a pawn so deep into blacks territory but
why can't really make use of it given
that a 7 just runs into King B 7 so the
pawn stays there for for a good while
Knight ef4 played 9 f7 castling kingside
so we finally reached the opposites like
casting situation let's zoom forward and
see how play is currently developing we
see black is expanding on the Kings side
and after apology for the knight comes
into play Knight to g5 props initiating
some trade now we see this very strange
move Knight a 7
which I'm trying to comprehend it does
free up the c6 square maybe this Bishop
wants to come back into play also maybe
there's ideas of Knights to b5
potentially harassing the Queen and also
pressuring this pawn on d4 we see the
Knights do get traded and after rook FB
one King to b7
this brings us to see I think one more
move has been played Queen to be - and
this brings us to the current position
where I like whites I like the fact that
White has more space blacks King is
somewhat dubiously placed just in the
center and seems like black just doesn't
have the the best coordination and seems
very possible that the white will look
to open up the center quite soon the
plan that sticks out to me is some idea
of rook to C 1 and C 4 whenever you're
upon sking is in the center and the
center is closed you want to look for
ways to open up more lines in this case
white would love to open up the C file
the what is the Queen's purpose
specifically on b2 though how does that
come into play I think Queen B 2 is
played to get out of the way of the C
pawn ok maybe not necessarily improving
improving the effectiveness of the Queen
but sometimes when when your pieces are
in the way of each other you have to
clear up clear up squares so things can
come into play more harmoniously and I I
do like Queen C - like in the earth
Queen - B - it can no longer be harassed
from where it was on c3 and it seems
like White has a very clear plan while
black it's not so clear what black is
trying to do here maybe there's some
idea of H 5 H 4 but seems a little bit
slow and it seems like White's plan is
just much quicker in this position
all right well we've seen where we stand
now the further record I got the players
flipped when I was introducing the game
U is actually 10th Dirk is ninth right
now so but after this it could be
anybody I mean they could everybody so
close right now in the standings you
could eat a whole bunch of us now I do
want to mention Christopher you escaped
from the jaws of defeat yesterday
against Sergey Azov had a seems like a
much worse rook ending but kept fighting
kept fighting kept fighting and he held
on for a draw and I think perhaps that
game gave him some momentum in going
forward in the tournament that was his
first first half point of events having
lost the first two games so sometimes
when you're in that situation where you
there's a couple games you draw a game
and it's time to start thinking about
winning some games yes I had something I
was about to say but the rumbling threw
me off a little bit Erik I gotta be
honest I don't know what they're
building upstairs might be a birdhouse
sounds serious
yeah it's a subway the Train possible
okay so another game that has caught my
eye we're staying in Group B right here
I want to look at Akshat versus Ashwin
mm-hmm two players very familiar to the
st. Louis crowd here this is just a
complete mess I'm counting material so
that's the one thing I do know how to do
it seems like materials currently equal
let's go back I was not looking at this
game earlier actually I was I noticed
Ashwin played a very rare opening
actually for high-level chess the
Alekhine's defense this is not something
you see every day in in modern
high-level play this is a type of thing
you would see maybe 100 years ago when
alekhine was still around the idea of
this opening is to provoke white to
overextend and then later counter punch
in the center and I I do like the
opening choice by Ashwin simply because
a shot has some issues with time
management as we see as we see
is currently below in minutes so I don't
want to take too long analyzing this
line but I do want to make a note that
it seemed like black just have a very
simple setup this is a type of thing
that you'll see very often in the
Scandinavian after Bishop to f5 rock
just has simple ways to complete
development and it seemed like I seemed
like Oxshott took a lot of time early on
and perhaps is not saving himself for
enough time in the current moment going
forward here simple play by black-white
does have a little less space and this
is one of the reasons why Bala kind is
not so popular on the high level it does
concede space but it is perhaps offbeat
enough that I can make the player or the
opponent think let's zoom forward
because both player is kind of doing
their own thing white does get the
bishop hair to Queen b3 attacking the
pawn in b7 black defends with Queen c7
rook FD 1 and the first first pawn break
of the game pawn to e5 trying to make
the minor pieces come to life especially
this bishop on g6 and the 9 and g7
well I would love to perhaps land on e5
if politic e5 and I take you 5 black and
perhaps breathe a bit easier but after
c5 action I play the counter attacking
move excuse me after E 5 ox not played
the counter attacking we see in the live
shot the game is over
whoa I think I think action has lost ok
let's go forward and try and figure out
what's new - which Aram has the victory
is black how did this happen Knight to
e5 did he lose on time can we get a
close-up of the fog I mean it's 30
second increment that would be that'd
just be very unfortunate to lose on
I create five wait a minute we do have
more moves whoa
okay the final position features a fork
where it seems like black is winning
material how did we get there
so let's get to this position still
equal material and then we can rule our
stall it's not a time lawsuit there's
still time on the clock but yes the fork
so first of all I'm a bit curious this
knight on e5 is hanging but if white
were to capture it were there any
tactics and I'm overlooking here maybe
there's idea of rook to D H work 88
where this Queen is tied down to
defending both the knights and the
bishop on e5 and perhaps this is what
was a bit scary for for the white side
so it seemed like a shot tried to be a
bit fancy with this move Knight to b5
removing the knight as a target and
perhaps hoping that after politic b5
Bishop take E 5 this would be a trade
and white is white would be perhaps
doing well here
but Ashwin played a somewhat invisible
move this is a type of move that is very
easy to overlook but very aesthetic in
the tactical nature Queen take d5 this
leaves the Queen attacked by at the
bishop but after Bishop takes e5 Knight
f3 check black wins the Queen right back
and a shot just resigned in this
position realizing that after the dust
settles King g2 and I take t4 black is
just up a piece if rift 84 the bishop
hangs in the end and just an extra night
for black so I would I would bet that
Oxshott just missed Queen take b5 very
unfortunate blunder but I mean that's
what happens when you're so long time
it's easy to miss these perhaps more
hard to see moves and now the Indian
player Ashwin Jerome has catapulted
himself to will sharing the top spot
with two and a half points along with
the
I'd love to talk to a Schwinn if we can
get him down here I would love to talk
to a Schwinn - we might have to fight
over who can oh I'll let you have okay
you could probably analyze a little bit
better than me all right
no way one of the real nice guys of the
chess world great an interview as well
so that's our first decisive game of the
day in either field and what else shall
we look at the games in Group A I'm just
glancing at the eval
they look very even so far is there
anything you wanted to go over Erik
first yeah there's a game that catches
my eye in Group B very imbalanced
position
the battle between Sergei azorath and
Conrad Holt just trying to make sense of
the the situation let's go back just a
few moves and see see what is going on
again whenever I'm switching to a new
position and just trying to let the
evaluation sink in I'm always starting
by counting material in this case white
is up two pawns but the king is very
exposed and black has two bishops in the
very open position there is pressure
along the F file there's this attack
against this rook on c1 so as played
about white played rook to d1 black kept
initiative with Queen g5 check and seems
like black is the one who's dictating
play despite being down material after
King to h1 Bishop h3 threatening classic
queen g2 checkmates I think white has
only one reasonable move here to play
rook to d1 and then after Queen f6 still
seems like black is keeping pressure
rook to g3 but maybe white is
consolidating the bishop is forced back
to c8
this seems like a very passive move but
I believe the idea is to simply
reposition the bishop all along this
it's very nice long diagonal to target
one of the greatest weaknesses in this
position is pawn in f3 and then after
Queen to e4 one more move has been
played Bishop to b6
and this is a current position but it
seems like within the last few moves
White has been able to keep everything
defended and now is perhaps looking to
expand
I do like whites whites chances here and
there's a potential mating idea which is
sticking out to me I'm not sure how it
could potentially work let's just play a
really bad move for black in this
position I'll give you some time here
yeah cuz we've got an tresor on he's
about to come in for an interview
yes let's continue looking at it in the
interim okay I wanted to mention that
white would really like to play a move
like Knight g6 provoking hthe six and
then somehow check along the h-file and
if I could check along h-file
this would be checkmate given that black
is black is not able to move to gh on
the bishop on c4 the problem here is
that move like Queen h4 or rook h3 are
not playable due to the fact that black
is covering h4 of the Queen and covering
h3 with the bishop so if that were to
either remove the Queen or the bishop
from covering these two squares there is
this Knight g6 possibility now the
question is what does white do in this
position - to try and make progress
given that it's probably no immediate
tactics and it seems like it seems like
white might still have to work to build
up some attack one kind of move that
pops out right away is a move like
Bishop to d3 just a simple maiden one
threat attempting to just capture the
pawn on a seven and sometimes moves like
this you want to consider these are
forcing moves where you have very direct
threats however black might be able to
respond in this case with a move like
this five not only defending a counter
attacking so I wouldn't be surprised if
Sergey takes his time in this position
he still has 16 minutes left for about
nine more moves until new 40 so we'll
have to keep an eye on this game but I
do want to welcome a special guest in
the
to do grandmaster ostrich I run after
winning is this your first win of the
turn no second second win them the tribe
a congratulations ah that's right again
that's right yeah we didn't get a chance
to talk to you then but it's good to
have you here now seemed like a quit II
quit fig tree today now I do want to ask
you because I mentioned earlier in the
vents you're you're working you have a
full-time job I mean not today is
Saturday so today's a weekend so did
that play in your favor do were you able
to sleep in oh yeah answer some energy
so yeah very rested so I guess that
helped him very nice and will you be
working in the morning for the round
starting Monday yeah everyday yes I'll
have a morning shift and then they were
nice enough to let me plays which I'm
really grateful for mm-hmm and so
obviously I have to make up for it and
you know later on overtime but it's fun
to play whenever I can
sure well that's work we're good to have
are very glad to have you here take us
through the game it seemed like you were
perhaps a bit inspired by the late
Alekhine yeah to to play some offbeat
opening yeah I mean I think me to play
the elephant for a while cuz I analyzed
it briefly and it never seemed like
quite had anything major and nowadays
because I don't really have enough time
to do that deep opening preparation so
I'm always looking for these lines where
it's not so bad but very playable and
the other kind is probably you know one
of the best opening for that kind of
chess and was the specific preparation
for Akshay I was speculating that maybe
there was a good choice against him
because he takes his time when in
someone yeah I mean I've been mean to
play for a while this seemed like the
perfect occasion to try it because he
I'm sure the very well prepared you know
very well preparing the openings and
I've been meaning thing that Kara can
these days and I figure if I play the
CARICOM then I probably face a lot of
preparation and I really I just want to
sleep in you know I don't want to I
don't want to stay that's enough sleep
is more important than heavy preparation
so in preparing for the alkyne did you
prepare like specific main lines or you
just try
to get a feel of the middlegame
structure I mean so when preparing I
forget one game against the other kind
where he played this takes this modern D
for an out of three and so I mean I had
analyzed the c6 Bishop of five and I
mean I knew I know that a lot of
Grandmaster games here so I was pretty
sure that you know even if even if I got
a slight you know what got some slight
advantage it wasn't too
it wasn't too bad was solid enough and
it seems like that what that's what
happened I mean white just had some nice
space advantage yeah I mean something
all this has been played before and you
know it's a rather typical structure
well black is solid white has a bishop
in space but black has some Connor play
d5 and so I guess for me what really
worked is that it apparent is really
surprised them because even for I think
like if you look at the move Knight if
three that's being played several
hundred times and it you probably took
about half an hour to make that move I
have three I move back after this has
been played several times and probably I
think a few other games and this you
know I think it probably took him about
half an hour to make this move so yeah
that's too much time this way especially
and I think somewhat quiet position I
think perhaps he was really calculating
f/4g four options which are interesting
mm-hmm I think they're not they desert
we played way more but I think it's
probably calculating those probably not
the type of thing you want to play
without prior preparation I'd looked at
it briefly but not I mean III know that
I'm not losing here so that's good
enough for me
so what was the turning point in this
game because it seemed like okay you
were you were maybe slightly worse but
then was it just time trouble for
anything with combination of things so
there was this moment where I played a
five and it looks I haven't checked the
computer yet but this looks very risky
cuz a c5 Bishop c4 mm-hmm right so I
think he also taught us a probably
mistake but after Bishop e7 I think he
realized that c5 with a little bit of a
I mean I mean your attacks f7 I defended
and then
this you know c5 is still hanging for
some time and so it's he's a little bit
overextended I'm still saw that I have
all my everything to play for
so I mean I still think it's probably
equal but I mean he probably thought he
had way he had much more than he
actually did mm-hmm so then later on C D
takes e5 Knight takes e5 so now Alma
counterplay is designed around trying to
exploit the c5 pawn so the Queen c4 my
ship if fade now I'm threatening the
plan takes you three should take c5 and
just a nice exchange soccer yeah I mean
I'm pretty sure this is better for me
because his entire Kings side looks
weakened III also looks weak maybe not
better but I'm definitely the one I mean
that would be a good situation together
when he's so long time definitely more
fun right so yeah I've been trying to
get to encounter play but c5 and so then
now I found this really interesting
tactic for 95 Queen d4 takes takes Queen
85 mm-hm and I get this nice bushy pixie
fabric takes e5 stuff and I think the
surprised him and so after Bishop to g5
you would play Bishop e5 haha I was
trying to comprehend what's going on
here I was thinking me to your rook 88
because it takes e5 yeah looks nicer
here he has two options when he complete
I mean there's one option that's a
little bit funny but so if he takes
bishop takes f6 then I can take on d4
and play c5 it's funny that that point
once again Wow yeah yeah the position is
just too delicate for a white bishop
defense if the poor would be so
absolutely white probably just much much
much better but you know I get this nice
e5 move yeah that's a nice nice thing to
see at the end of the variation which
maybe he would necessarily see quickly
enough given the time situation but so I
mean apart from this he had two other
options Bishop c7 was one and I take on
d4 he takes on a5
then I take on c3 and then I take on e
to
now maybe he can take another six go for
this routine game and this I mean I'm
pretty sure it looks very draw but I'm
definitely mean I have more time I'm
pushing you know and you're in the
driver's seat yeah yeah for sure and so
the other option is instead of Bishop d7
Queen a4 so then I take on a four Knight
takes a four route takes e5 Bishop of
three rook c8 now I think if he wants to
he could win back c6 pawn the rook c1
but I think I can route see what I can
probably score Bishop e3 and if you take
songs c6 then it takes and play a rookie
to take back yeah this I mean I'm
attacking a two if he moves as a
four-night I get Bishop c5 I mean I
think I'm still better over here yeah it
looks very pleasant
now all these variations were you
recalculating on his time like when he's
thinking no I think this is a good on my
time I think nah I already sort of saw
this Queen if I'm idea a few moons ago I
didn't it was not a fully formed idea
yet so when he played this Queen was it
Queen before yeah when he played Queen
before it was here I was thinking for a
long time I was also considering playing
Pontic c5 pawn sexy fabric 88 sure looks
which looks very natural yeah and you
know it looks at first it looks like
it's losing material because of Bishop
takes e5 but you know if Queen takes e5
and route 61 check and so I'm not losing
in material
but here I mean I would I don't know if
there's a great idea to have a queen III
open it entirely sure what to do it
seems like you took the right approach
in the game going for Queen 85 yeah I
figured if I'm at the very least have a
better in game right now when you play
Queen a5 do you consider Knight d5 I
really check to the media so it was
actually quite lucky that's Lucy
I'm fairly conserved might be five how
long did it take for you to find Queen
ZigBee five I mean absolutely players I
saw that wasn't working nice I mean for
a while I've been looking at this motif
at night of three check I mean it was
sort in the back of my mind and then
when he played 95 for us the first I'll
surprise another like wait
I can just go over here and I was a
little bit I thought okay maybe he might
have something we should take c6 and get
some you know two minor pieces but it's
you know I got my petition is lucky
enough that Knight takes d4 protects c6
that's true yeah yeah yeah things worked
up
oh nice finish this brings you to what's
your current score two and a half two
and a half out of four is so plus score
still many games to go any weekend plans
now that you're not you're not working
this weekend is it mostly eat sleep
chess or and you get more sleep okay
I'll let you get back to sleep yeah sure
and we are going to take a quick
commercial break and we'll be back with
more coverage from the 2018 fall chess
classic
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like VA 3
is an illegal move here because white
masters pawn two squares are one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
gotta say flanking in seven games e2 and
I'll try because four against Lawrence
and now he's going to play something
against me which would discuss the
playing during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we find this one Noah
Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
Chester to work like this I don't think
it does well maybe it does well that's
me regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of my quality of life has
just gone downhill tremendous me because
I'm actually sharing the office with the
guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
welcome back everyone to the studio at
the 2018 fall chess classic I'm
international master Eric Rosen and we
have another special guest in the studio
Grandmaster Bruges in the Cobian after
drawing his game against crime master
hammer how are you doing far hi hi Eric
hi everyone it's it's one okay I mean I
have two out of four I have three decent
games one win two draws and one really
bad game and pretty ashamed of that loss
I mean I just for some reason decide to
experiment with Scandinavian and just
back wire pretty badly here so it was a
terrible loss for me so yeah how do you
end up like regrouping after a game like
that you try and just forget about it
and move on or did you change anything
in your playing style yeah I just wanted
to have a little fun and tried this
opening and the only reason I played it
because my opponent had only two
resolved against this opening so he lost
two games and I thought you know might
bring some memories back but looks like
he just prepared you know after the
success he he looked it up and he was
just quite ready play the best move sent
I I basically played one really bad move
in that game after long castle be kind
of casually like if it's a blitz a rapid
game you might get by it but long game
is just played one bad move and I
couldn't get back at the game after this
it was just like one really bad move
it's tough yeah then I just had a good
game yesterday against bruising I went I
won with white there's a good
preparation I played the Fabiano line
against nimza with four g3 we saw that
yeah brother Fabio so play that then dad
it was a good game and today was just I
think a pretty decent game against
Humber I was black and pretty accurately
yeah seemed like a very solid game
nothing too eventful I think that
critical moment this maybe of before the
move Shh well let's go forward maybe
because most of it it's theory until we
deviate from one of his game today I was
I had a very brief preparation because
Grandmaster hammer plays you know a 44
c4 Knight f3 so hard to prepare I wasn't
just going to spend two three hours
preparing stages you know I expected
some efore and I saw a few plays d4
maybe I'll just play something solid so
so he actually had a game against
symma noggin Stein with the same line
last year and so this is pretty popular
bishop before 90 to 96 are not displayed
minigames Hikaru Nakamura let's say this
seems like a very topical I mean it is
there are some important ideas here so
after he counts as the bishop has
nothing to do already on before so just
go back Bishop e7 a3 Bishop f6 okay rook
c1 maybe he's another move here because
we should be - there's a Bishop h7
tactic think they can take the h7 Quincy
to check winning the bishop but he yeah
Brooke p1 he played and here I played
rootkit I think this is a pretty
accurate move here because it's not so
clear what white is going to do now
because I want to play 95 so he played
Knight f3 which allows Bishop g4 if but
let's say he tries to play a
prophylactic move first with h3 then I
think 95 simply equalizes because now if
the bishop goes to E - I have Bishop f5
with tempo hitting the rock on b1 and if
the bishop goes on c2 it just looks
awkward I might I might be able to even
play Knight c4 here yes since black is
here yeah maybe black maybe not better
but very comfortable this is all part of
some like opening preparation so be
honest I didn't prepare to him I just
saw that he had a game and he told me
he's apparently g6 here in Slovakia
Grandmaster August 9 and you know it I
hate that white is better there so I
think the next few moves are pretty
forced so Bishop g4 h3 which page 5 okay
now what to do it doesn't play g4 it's
very difficult to find a useful move
here because I'm very active my bishops
are very active on f6 on h5 we should be
too I even have bishop g6 so I play g4 I
think this is forced Bishop g6 takes
Queen d3 okay critical moment and again
because if I give him couple of moves it
plays rook f d1
King G - maybe white is a little bit
better so here I realized I have to
clear very
concrete here so just g5 I think is a
strong move attacking the bishop forcing
him to g3 and the next one is default
yeah this is nice move very cheap yeah
because trying to equalize yes yes and
now if he takes 94 just equalizes
immediately so yeah I'm just Queen takes
before we should be forced to play E for
and now actually another accurate move
in my opinion because if I play Bishop
e5 right away my rook on FIV five it's
not ideally placed and in this line
after we exchange everything so that's
why I insert so can you explain why the
rook isn't because it cannot go too many
squares only five and he will play let's
say look everyone I think it's very
close to equality but maybe he's tiny
bit better there but I played the bet I
got a better version of this position
because I played Queen e7 very strong
move attacking the pawn on e4 so they
essentially forcing rook fe1 and now
Bishop e5 because if I was coming now
and now Bishop if I just forces the
liquidation here so I think he has to
take otherwise he could be worse
so we trade everything and okay here he
had an option maybe to play rugby d1
keep for all the rooks but again black
is I think absolutely fine here it's
route 88 and I was gonna play Mookie d8
actually so I can put the other room to
see it so I think I'm at least equal
here so he played rook AC one I played
okay c8 now we trade one pair of rooks
Rock d1 I can't play rook e8 here that
would be an inaccuracy because he will
take on d4 Queenie for takes on before
rookie four and now inserts roopd a
check and then rugby sevens and sat down
upon an endgame so of course I'm not
gonna allow this I play Duke teed and
I'm absolutely fine here I thought we're
just gonna probably repeat with rook the
rook d2 rock Devon I didn't see too many
things for him or for me either but he
decided okay maybe this a6 wasn't the
best maybe I should have just played
King g7 because this allowed the c5
squared but I think nevertheless is just
it's just completely fine for me
I didn't see too many winning to play
for a win I mean I can only play for a
win if I can somehow force him to play
f3 but he's never gonna do that because
that then the king will be weak
I cannot force him because every time I
rocky will take on d4 how would you take
advantage if he does play a three here
if you plays f3 it's it's not in
concrete not in concrete here but I have
to I will try to you know it's probably
still very close to a draw but maybe at
sample and try to get the rook to the C
file I'm not sure how it will work like
like let's say I'll put the King on h7
just just give you an idea and at some
point I'll play Queen f4 and if the when
the rook is already gone from d2 to d1 I
play rook c8 so yeah and let's say you
know - yeah exactly so something like
this I guess actually is very weakening
to G yeah so but that's why you know f3
would be very I was hoping for it but
you know he's not gonna do it mmm I mean
otherwise I get the winning chances so
then it we played rooks and this is just
forced we get a disposition okay I
probably can also make a draw rook g5 I
was trying to make a 5 work because that
that you know he played bit risky
because you know if the rook gets
trapped there
but this deep one is gonna Queen work
but I can't he has gtex f5 and very
quickly he takes on g6 and rook t6 is in
time to get there
otherwise my D pawn is very quick
actually it's going down and the King on
g2 is cut off so I thought it was a bit
risky for him to go for this but
actually it works out fine for him so I
go King f6 Rock d5 King b6 look at the
8th King g7 now if you place let's say
route p7 this is already asking Ruby
sorry this is already asking for trouble
d3 now take King g6 I'm not sure if I'm
playing for the win here but at least he
has to in this past pollen scary yes I
find well maybe this is just winning
actually no this just just wins actually
yeah yeah cos 45 maybe a rupee a maybe
rook b8
rook t4 ok this probably very dangerous
teruki 8th King D 5
yeah I think yeah rookie 1 D 2 Kings
before I mean this is just I mean
information where I could trade the rook
simply not not in this position because
I go King C 3 quickly I can see 3 is
winning so I think you can only lose
here so he played so we just send up we
end up repeating I mean there was an
interesting idea he could have played
King F 3 here after rookies on the 8mm
but here I have F 5 very strong and now
let's say he takes takes and I mean if
he goes rootbeer again I have this move
maybe you can try this maybe it's a draw
still this line actually here PP 8 D 3
rupees 7 kingi 6 I rock pH King is 7
probably I don't know if I'm winning
after rook I may be looking for is just
winning still what's attractive yeah so
look e8 King d5 ok so here's some kinky
trim ok have to be may be careful a
little bit here maybe you have just
taking too much risk here I'm playing
for yeah I probably just just go bad so
rugby 8 I just got repaired I just go
back D 3 rupees 7 k music repeat I just
cooking yourself and I think he has a
key nice a game seven he has to give
perpetual otherwise let's say in that
line if he plays rook g8 he loses to DQ
rook Jiwon and you want yeah so yeah it
was just seemed like a quiet kind of
ball game
it's normal game i test i play to play
fine and neutralized it you know with
the black pieces now do you know who
you're playing tomorrow i'm saying i
like three if alex a three of tomorrow
who's doing very well very well any
thoughts in that game and yeah he's
finished by 12 oh I will just prepare a
little bit today and I think most
important is to be fresh sure I mean
every game is gonna be tough so but he's
playing quite well so far I mean he's
got two wins and two draws so now when
the pairings went up well before the
tournament started
do you perhaps do preparation for each
opponent or are you doing preparation
day by day I'm doing day by day because
you know my schedule was quite busy I
had a lot of things I was doing before
the tournament so I didn't have too much
time to just prepare and plus again once
again you don't want to just over
prepare too much because these people
can surprise you and you never know
what's gonna happen here I will just go
a little bit of preparation just more
try to stay fresh and just play play
chess sure
well I'll let you go go prepare get some
rest and best of luck tomorrow thank you
and now we are going to take a look at
the remaining games still going there
are a number of games still going on it
seems like in both groups scrolling
through here trying to figure out which
game is the most exciting perhaps we can
go back to the Sergey Hazara of Conrad
Holt game because Queens have been
traded and seems like White has
maintained the pawn advantage let's go
back to where Queens were still on the
board oh wow
after Bishop to b6 where we last saw the
position when I was looking at it I was
trying to make ideas of Knight to g6
work but we see that white went for a
very surprising move rook to g6 and I
don't believe the roof can be taken
because if G take or hthe 698 g6 King h7
would be forest and then the rook hangs
on f8 but check so Queen f5 was played
and then after Queens are traded seems
like white is is just having a better
end game
nice little discovered check here 96
King h8 rook g5 and after g6 and I take
out 5 now there is some hope for black
with the opposite color Bishop situation
but I would still have to put my money
on Azure of to come out victorious in
this game now I do want to welcome back
Ben Simon in the studio good to have you
back after a couple long interviews yeah
very exciting stuff it's good to finally
hear from var even though today
it was a drop you know he he's really
not taken off skyrocketed like he does
sometimes but there's still a lot more
left to play so it's always cuz you're
here from Bardot and he does have a
pretty big online following two very
notable lecturer for the st. Louis Chess
Club YouTube channel I know you've
you've recorded many of his lectures and
aren't there a few videos with over a
million views
look I've lost track how many of our
lectures I've recorded but I know that
var has the most viewed single video on
our YouTube channel it's a well and
because it has just a phenomenal title
it's it's for beginners it's a beginner
in chess video and you know 90% of chess
players out there are beginners right so
especially the YouTube community yeah
yeah yeah so it's a great video and
there's so much more to check out on
this youtube channel
assuming you're watching on youtube or
on us chess champ Scott so there is one
game that we have not looked at at all
Eric I believe at well at least one game
and gonna make me guess what that is
well in Group B actually a document
Jacobson versus Mordy Abadi I don't
think we've glanced at that yet let's go
and take a look
Brandon Jacobson one of the youngest
players in Group B one of the only non
geumsan group to be but having a very
good tournament so far and it looks like
he's putting some pressure against his
pretty formidable opponent I'll shine
more ADEA body black seems quite passive
here King on g7 rooks not so active and
like completely out of play and seems
like white is attempting to make
progress on the Kings side to advance
this this outside past pawn on the H
file all the lost move that was played
as king to g5 seems like h6 is a very
clear threat now the one thing I would
be a little concerned about if I were
white in this position is this rook on
e4 I did mention that the knight is out
of play but mine is out of play because
it's preventing the rook on before from
getting back in play there cannot access
any of these three squares all of them
are cover
by black so it is a question can white
make progress without using this rook
which is stuck on the Queen side I do
like White's chances still to play h6
and then perhaps when the time is right
maybe play rookie - and King f6 and just
keep gaining space and this H pawn will
be very close to queening so both
players have a lot of time here they're
on move 45 and this could be a very long
fight ain't interesting to see I'm
curious about that rook on b4 I mean it
is a do you ever see a future where that
rook is not trapped or entombed in that
area anymore
well the issue for black is that even
though the rook has no moves
there's no way to immediately trap it
like black cannot attack the rook while
keeping all the squares around the rook
controlled if a move like knight c6 were
to be played then the rook can escape
via b3 and then wiggle the way around
the pawns and come back into play well
what what if white we didn't want to
wait for that what if what if you took
the DF rope down to the first rank and
then moved it over didn't want to try to
remove that night it's actually a really
interesting idea I was I was having all
the focus on the kingside but that's a
good point that this is a potential
resource in the position and if the rook
does come to a 1 the knight is forced to
retreat to one of these squares a6 could
be weak and then the rook can perhaps
come back to the a file it's a very nice
idea I think the question is can white
afford to spend the time to play rook f1
or k1 or does white want to use the time
first to play h6 and and go for a king
side play but yeah now that you
mentioned it I I do like this idea of
rook F long enough to see if he decides
to play it there are games in group a
yuriko's above as black against Lazaro
burrs own we haven't glanced at that one
yet I think we should probably through
that there's a lot of action going on
file any captures coming up what's going
on here so let's go back a few moves and
see how play to foul up
seems like White's white was a one
looking for this queenside expansion
pawn c5 now this is kind of a late
middle game approaching the endgame
where white is now already wanting to
create a passed pawn to have something
to play for in the position and the next
several moves we see this pawn just
stays on c5 and there's a lot of tension
between these two pawns black cannot
take right away because there's a pin
along the B file so after Bishop to d5
94 that should take me for rook to e4
Queen f6 I like the white though the way
white is playing in this position Queen
a3 oddly he supports the pawn but also
attacks this a7 pawn prompted black to
play this move rook to c7 and then rook
to b1 applying more pressure on d6
97 is played and if I'm not mistaken
this looks like a pawn sacrifice by
black it seems like white might be able
to get away with taking the pawn twice
on b6 but maybe this isn't what white
wanted to go for it cuz now white
doesn't have this this potential for
this very far advanced pawn and then
white is left with pretty glaring
weakness on d4 black would have just a
number of ways to build up pressure with
both Brooks coming to the D file
combined with Knight f5 so it's very
possible that black will win back the
pond quite soon
so instead white played this move rook
back to see one after rook t8 rook see
495 very nice outpost square for the
knight not easy for white to remove
after Queen b3 now we finally see a
capture between the pawns after B takes
e5 D takes e5 and rook dc8 and it seems
like that black just has overwhelming
pressure against the C pawn seems like
white may have overextended and now is
regretting the fact that okay black has
very strong battery on the C file and
it's not so easy for white to defend the
pawn effectively given that black has
Queen e7 coming a move that light would
like to play here is something like
Queen a3 but then after Queen e7 the
pawn is now attacked three times and
pinned to the Queen so we do have
several more moves that have been played
to want to update the board here looks
like Black has managed to win the pawn
going back to after rook c8 yeah white
played kind of a sad movie one just for
treating had to say goodbye to the pawn
and black goes up upon Queen d4 check
and ice kind of in between move
provoking King H 1 and then Queen takes
e5 keeping a battery on the C file
white plays h3 and then Queen f2 and one
more move has been played rook to be won
this brings us to the current position I
think this is one of the few games that
have still not reached move forward
either on move 36
both players have just over a minute so
you might see some some time scramble
action always something to look forward
to so you would give an advantage here -
coos above a huge advantage to say yeah
who's above having extra pawn very
stable position which everything is is
solid and defended and now black is
looking to create some attack it looks
like Queen d7 has been played actually
wait no it's blacks move Oh black played
g6 I'm creating some more looped for the
King and then Queen to d7 still three
more moves to make until time control
time is ticking for coos above and
there's a question how to actually break
through on the Kings side I mean the
structure does not seem so appealing for
black pretty much or for white I should
say pretty much everything on light
squares really weakens the dark squares
and I'm sure black would be dreaming of
somehow getting the Knights to be more
effective in attacking the the King side
but for the time being it the rook is
attacked on c8 and the first thing that
jumps out here is a move rook to c2
which we might see when we see Brook to
c7 or solid move just gaining tempo on
the Queen I mean this is a position
which maybe Bach doesn't have to be in
too much rush now that everything's
defended like the the pawn defends the
knight defends a queen or defends the
rook which depends upon and attacks the
Queen so it's some nice coordination for
black and because they're so low on time
I think the strategy might be just to
reach time control and then get a
position where you have enough time to
figure out how to actually win the game
and the the real last game we haven't
looked at I don't think we've looked at
settlement and Lenderman am I correct in
saying that well this is the key matchup
of the day of course so we looked at it
very first yes we did check it out it
was very kind of quiet peaceful opening
there are some fireworks taking place
and they are they have just reached move
40 so there is it's time added for both
players I am counting the material here
and I see that lunderman is up upon four
pawns against five funds however when
you're when you're up upon your opponent
has less pawns means your opponent has
more open files in this case White has
the open F file and a half open e file
the half open G file and perhaps white
can use this to perhaps get some counter
play given that there's some juicy
targets especially along that file right
now in the position this bishop is
pinned to the Queen velocity by Black
was actually Queen f6 so is black
walking into a pin and I'd be curious
now for white if there's any immediate
way to exploit this but
seemed like the bishop is very well
defended on a five given that it's
supported by the pawn there there's no
way for white to effectively remove this
bishop immediately I do want to go back
to the Brazilian Cruiser bought game
because some moves have been played sure
and it seems like they're on the verge
of reaching time control black has
brought the rook back to or intellects
territory after King to g7 Queen d6
finally we see Roxy - this is a very
powerful combination especially towards
the end of the game when you have two
major pieces on your opponent second
rank I know I've I've talked about this
in many days this this previous week but
when it's a combination of rook pluses
Queen + Queen it's a very powerful
mating combination and after white plays
a for one more move has been played by
black rook to d2 and this is move forty
time has been added and okay the rook on
d2 not only helping pressure the second
ring but now also aligned with the White
Queen and it seems pretty dire for a
White's I mean it seems like White's
only hope is to try and get counter play
against the black king
it looks like Brazil played a5 there
calmly 5 on a5 that's our random move I
would think that light would want to
remove the Queen maybe go for something
like Queen to e5 check seems very random
I mean I was thinking Queen e5 check if
the King moves to h7 I would really like
to get the rook down to v8 the problem
is the work is tied down to defending
the bishop so maybe white is realizing
here that things are just kind of stuck
I think the rook is tied down can't
really get in to play the Queen only has
one check on e5 then after King h7
the King is it's very safe and there's
no way for light to infiltrate so
perhaps a5 is just a waiting with just
posing the question to black
howís baka actually even crashed through
in this position and convert the tak one
thing to point out here is that if night
comes to e3 which seems like kind of the
final straw an attempt to break to break
White's position here then the night is
less in position to cover the the
blacking side and after a queen e5 check
King h7 this Knight is no longer
defending at six square and white might
got some counter play here with a move
like Queen f6 given that okay now
there's a threat against f7 and while it
lacks attack looks crushing it's not
immediately forcing black would love
love to take on f1 or g2 but these moves
are in checks and that would give white
to capture on f7 with check so I'm
curious here how black will actually
make progress and an attempt to to crash
through what would happen if you go back
here a couple moves and say the Queen
popped in to f6 but where you were just
analyzing oh so going forward if let's
imagine ninety-three Queenie five
teenage southern Queen f6 okay Oh
the problem is White's running made into
yeah okay so I was yeah I was I was
thinking well King ga-ga-ga still works
mate so I think black would be fit like
if this position occurred back would
have to move rook d7 which is prop still
playable and then maybe there's some
idea for black and playing nyah 593 I
think it might come down to how black
will ultimately improve the Knights I
mean it's a very stable piece in this
position but I feel like in order to win
the game that I has to help in some way
in attacking the Kings side it's just a
question what the right maneuver is
there's another idea here across to play
g5 and Knight to f4 where the knight can
simultaneously attacked and
and help defend so I'm sure I'm sure
black is going to be taking his time to
consider these possibilities still no
new results in yet in Group B we have
three games still going on
we have glanced at all of them at this
point you and you and Zurich Sal it'll
crazy I don't know if you check that one
out I mean that was crazy when we last
saw things maybe have settled down a
little bit his pieces have come off the
board and we see okay I'm trying to
count these pawns White has seven pawns
Bach has six months the White has an
opponent manage and this a seven pawn
landed on a six a long time ago I moved
14 I want to go back to that points when
black played a six and white just
captured and this pawn had survived ever
since which seems pretty miraculous
given that it seemed like a weak pawn in
Black's territory but going forward to
the current position this is one of
White's biggest assets now given that
okay it's two squares away from queening
it is currently blockaded but it has to
be under constant I of the Black Knights
and meanwhile the knight is just stuck
on a 7 so sometimes to win these
positions you need multiple multiple
assets in the position white already has
very strong asset on a6 it's possible
that white might like to create some
some play on the Kings side maybe by
going for a move like Queen f4 and if
the Queen could perhaps enter via g5 or
h6 then blacks king it looks safe for
the time being but maybe I can start
poking around to create some additional
law additional chances to make progress
and the last move that was played is
Queen to b4 so I assume that this is
what Christopher wants to do just bring
the Queen into blacks territory
and this is not an easy move to stop in
Korean f4 is basically unstoppable now
it's the question - black does he just
have to sit around and faces do or is
there any counter play one thing that
white does have to pay attention to
what's imagine black just plays a
waiting move let's say Queens e8 and
then Queen f4 when the Queen moves to at
four it does concede the B file and
maybe blacks Queen can enter via b2 or
via b4 so this could get crazy between
age six Queen B - might you have to be
careful as well so it's very intriguing
intriguing game these situations don't
happen too often where okay black is
very much restricted there's already the
a pawn seems like white is in full
control it's just a question how
Christopher is going to make progress
and I will stay I will say that I've
played Stephen zerk a few times before
and he's a tough player to crack I've
never been him he's being me to be me at
least once or twice very strong players
so we'll see if the youngster can take
him down
absolutely another game that in Group E
that I'm looking at see if any progress
can really be made once again Jacobsen
and more the Abadi the game with the
trapped rook on b4 and the H pawn of
Jacobson is it has advanced to the sixth
rank but I don't know okay I don't know
if anything can be working here for why
is this even I mean with blacks move
rook t8 it seems like the rook is just
waiting around like Al Shean has no
active player after h6 Keeney chaydez
okay white has got the pawn to h6 but
now it's right and the pawn can only go
so far upon h7 that would concede the g7
square which white probably doesn't want
to allow
so I mean the only idea in this position
that I see is the one that you mentioned
earlier rook F one two a one two try and
kick the Knights and it's a question
does he go for it no he went for work F
six perhaps more ambitious move focusing
on the kingside perhaps targeting this
pawn on e6 somewhat of a backwards pawn
and the problem here for black black
wouldn't really like to play pony five
cops trying open the position and
exploit White's King but when every five
is played white would probably be more
than happy to capture it and then that
would free up the rook on before via the
fourth-ranked and seems like Al Shean
it's still stuck doesn't want to make
any commitments he 5 is not the type of
move that he would like to play letting
this rook activate very quickly so I do
like this move rook f6 seems like a very
controlled move and I mean White's plan
might be just Bishop f7 just going after
the pawn I'm thinking like this should
f7
King g6 there's there's only so much
progress that White King can make but if
Bishop f7 it's played black might have
to play rook d6 and it just seems like
black is is very much stuck I'm
wondering if maybe even the king could
come to e5 to just create an outpost
with the king probably that an idea like
heaney v it does a lot Knight to c6 so I
always have to be careful of the night
coming back into play where you might
least expect it
but I'll Shawn has a lot of time here
and because he has seems like he's a 1
on the defense he might start to use his
time and this could be a very long
fights I mean if he feels under across
sure if he's uncertain about anything
he's gonna take his time and this could
lead to a game which could go well
beyond another hour hour and a half do
you see the rooks being traded off the
board and this thing goes to a draw
perhaps in the future or do you think
that one of
is likely to make some kind of mistake
it me is a mistake likely in this kind
of position I feel like why does the one
who's trying to kind of poke and prod
and provoke a mistake sometimes when you
you have full domination but you're not
crashing through sometimes the way you
win is by provoking a mistake and the
way to do that is for sometimes move
around try different ideas try and wear
it down tire out your opponent because
the longer the game goes more tired
these players get and I know Al Shean
has been covering from from being sick
the last few days so I don't know if
Randy knows this but that might play
into a strategy of prolonging the game
and trying to just to just consume or
forces opponent to consume as much
energy as possible yeah I mean it's like
we're giving out like the the fight
corner secrets here but the thing is
there's so many players in this field
who came just came to st. Louis they're
like either jet lag drive been sick you
know it's a it's like half the field so
you know it is it is what it is what I'd
like to do right now though is talk
about some upcoming programming at the
st. Louis chess club we'll be presenting
here right right here on YouTube and our
affiliated websites so this is the fall
chess classic first of all and you're
not gonna have to wait long for our
final seasonal event this year it's the
winter chess classic it's going to be
the same format as this one we have 210
player round robins with a $36,000 prize
fund up for grabs and you can watch that
in u.s. chess champs calm and then not
too long after that we have a norm of n
it's called the st. Louis Invitational
once again to ten player round robins
with a $15,000 prize
current fund and that's because these
two fields are exclusively fighting for
norms as well as that prize money but
we're gonna have a field looking for
their GM norms and then a field looking
for their International Master norms as
well now on to bigger things on the
world stage we have a little something
coming up called the world chess
championship
from London England today in chess is
the name of our show where we take a
look at the game of the day starting on
November 9th and going through the 28th
and who knows it may go past the 28th if
there is a playoff if the match is tied
6 to 6 we invite you to join us at st.
Louis chess club org and on our YouTube
channel as we look at one of the most
anticipated world chess championships
ever as Fabiano Cara Juana is the first
American to challenge for the title the
lineal title since Bobby Fischer in 1972
and also to complement that in today in
chess we have the Women's World Chess
Championship which is going to be crazy
because it's a 64 player knockout event
as June when June doesn't stand a good
chance to retain her title as she runs
the gauntlet from the very first round
of 64 all the way to the finale that
goes and that starts on November 2nd
actually but we will have coverage
starting on November 9th along with the
World Championship and then we round out
the year with the grand chest tour
finale it's in London but London chess
classic has a new format this year where
instead of being just another points
event for the GCT we've ended the point
stage and we know the top four players
that are going to the London Classic to
play in a knockout it's going to be a
series of classical rapid and blitz
games with $300,000 prize fund on the
line and the winner will be the 4th
grand chest tour champion and I mean as
a too far-fetched to say that Fabiano
Cara Juana could be walking out as the
world chess and grand chest tour
champion that would be incredible I mean
I'm I'm rooting for Fabiano and if he
wins the world championship wins the
grand chess to her that's got to be a
spectacular finish to the year but I
mean chess fans it seems like has have
so much to look forward to these next
just couple months they really do yeah
and that's just going into the end of
2018
it really doesn't ever stop here at the
st. Louis chess club even the events
that aren't here we've got you covered
and reminder we are still gonna be with
you for the next five days yeah we've
got five more rounds we're only halfway
home
there are still five games in progress
in these rounds but I'm not sure if any
of them are gonna end very soon Eric how
do you feel about it yeah seems like
some I mean the game still going a lot
of players have had the extra time to
kind of settle down take their time and
I would expect a lot of these games to
be pretty big fights I do want to go
back to the Sergey Azhar of Conrad Hulk
game for just a moment because earlier I
was thinking that Azhar of had good
winning chances having material
advantage in this position we can see
he's still up a pawn but it's obstacle
our bishops and I don't think that White
has any great chance to break through
Pawnee for was just played these endings
are very tricky sometimes they're
deceiving you might might think that
Bach just has a fortress when sometimes
it can take some very precise defense to
hold on it's very clear that white would
like to play a five and then maybe
someday break through the problem for
white is especially Piz always defending
along the long diagonal so if Fox just
plays let's say a waiting move in this
position just improve the king with King
f6 and like plays a move like pawn a5
then in black can keep waiting
I should mention there there's a trick
here where if black plays Bishop a1
attempting to provoke a six white can
not play a six but play b6 and this
would be this would be a dream scenario
for his R of breaking through two-on-one
majority where this Bishop can't really
comment back into play too quickly if
Bishop take a five is simply B take a
seven and if pawn take b6 very key move
pawn a six
and there would be no bishop f2 due to
the fact that people in b6 would be
obstructing the bishop so Bishop II 1
would be just a terrible blunder the
bishop wait a second Eric okay I
apologize after the the b6 that you
speculated it could Bishop before happen
this is before the problem is white just
wants to take on a7 make it okay yeah it
yeah if pawn d7 there leave it should be
six but okay of course the bishop should
stay all along this diagonal and I'm not
sure how white is going to end up making
progress maybe there's one trick here to
play King g2 but it is it is box but
let's say black plays another waiting
move like okay King f7 if I plays Kingi
- this could be very sneaky
it leaves the pawn on h4 undefended but
if Bishop take a tour then you still
have the same idea b6 and this Bishop is
now not in the right position to defend
against this Queen side breakthrough and
again if want a d6 pawn a six so I think
what might happen is we're gonna see
these pawns come to a five and B 5 and
then we're probably going to see King G
to where the bishop will probably be
chased away and then white should have
the plan of perhaps maneuvering is king
to the Queen side or maybe there's still
some hope for white - to come home with
a full point here given that this bishop
seems constantly tied down to have
stopping this breakthrough and meanwhile
the king is also a bit tied down if the
King runs too far to the Queen side
that'll that would allow white to play
Bishop g6 and pick up the opponent h5 so
it's a very intriguing position and I
think the fact that white has this
majority combined with the fact that
this pawn on h5 is a long-term targets
there's still some chances for Sergei to
perhaps grind down this end game
looking good for Sergei azeroth well I
think we are running into the end of our
program for today so we'll dip out in
just a moment but any final thoughts for
today Eric um I mean this event has been
fun to watch so far are lots of exciting
games I do want to make a note here that
our pumpkin feels a bit lonely and it's
been a while but I did buy a smaller
slightly smaller pumpkin it shows ago no
yeah dad
this pumpkin needed some additional
decoration as a as a stem it does have a
stem is this even a pumpkin it looks
awfully small pumpkins come in all
shapes and sizes all right I'm sure
there's a metaphor for life somewhere in
there so that'll do it for today we
thank you for joining us this show was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tammie Hyde was the
streamer today our graphics and audio
man is Isaac Krantz
technical director is Danny Machuca and
we invite you to join us tomorrow on
Sunday for around number five as we come
in but well two and a half hours late
3:30 p.m. Central Time at us chess
champs calm the round begins at 1:00
p.m. central so you can check out the
games as they happen on the chess 24
module on the site so I'm Ben Simon I'm
Eric Rosen and until tomorrow we say so
long from the Show Me State
[Music]
you